I came at you like a wrecking ball - Aah!
Wow!
Kiddies- What the heck?
Obstacle course.
Aah!
I didn't do anything!
Obstacle course.
Ow!
I'm still, aah!
Obstacle course, ha ha!
[LAUGH]
Hardcore.
Schnell.
Oh.
Well son we go through this together
apparently.
Oh my God, where we going?
Take two multiple shn, aah!
Once more into the schnell.
You missed me, bitch.
Suck on that.
IchEssAuchNieNutellaAus'NemleerenGlas!
[SOUND].
Hey, alright you kiddies.
Aah!
Ha ha!
>> Neon rope swing.
Okay, I'm not.
This is the only natural way to ride a
bicycle, kid.
Hope you know this.
Hope you understand.
All right.
Let's try this.
Let's see what happens.
Splits in the air!
Ow!
I love it!
Fight Club challenge!
Welcome to the Fight Club.
Well what happens here?
[LAUGH]
Is this it?
Is this really it?
Is this all you have?
[LAUGH]
Way to,
My God, it's so brutal.
No, You stabbed yourself.
No, you only got my, God!
Superman versus Horphin.
Horphin?
Woosh, okay.
Oh, Oh, Oh God, no, no.
[MUSIC]
Aw, come on.
Burn you... What? The name of the level was called
drop.
Can't go wrong here.
[SOUND]
Oop, oop, oh god.
Bottle run,
[SOUND]
Oh God oh God oh...
[LAUGH],
Bottle run.
Okay, doing it right, doing it right,
doing it right so tight.
Doing it right, what's up with this bike?
[SOUND]
[NOISE]
Nice!
BMX pro test.
So does that means where protesting BMX's.
[LAUGH]
Oh you're so funny.
[NOISE]
No, no oh,
Oh wow that was... That was a doozy on the
balls!
Destroy the wall.
Oh, ho, ho, ho.
Oh, that's so cool.
Look at this!
It's like the coolest thing!
I'm going to run out of balls here but.
Aw!
This is so cool!
God damn it!
I, aah!
Aw, look at me go.
I'm so good.
Yay!
Oh no.
Oh good.
Wow, hello.
Yep!
Come on!
Yeah!
[SOUND].
That was quick.
Epic rope swing.
Let's just see how aah!
Spike fall.
Well, let's go.
Wee,
[SOUND],
[LAUGH].
That was my first try.
Die you bitch, get in that alien, yum, oh
what, aah.
Sword throw, up, yeap, no.
Sword throw, yeap, yeap, okay, up the butt
for you, oh my, oh god.
Oh, God.
What the?
Whoa ho ho ho.
Whoa.
All right, now.
Whoop dee doo dee.
Oh, not dead yet.
Oh, I was clear.
Bye son!
Sword throw.
Deluxe.
Deluxe edition?
Why is it deluxe?
Oh God Santa what are you doing?
No!
That doesn't feel right.
Scamper dogs, I'm a strong independent
woman.
Who don't need no man!
Can you stop doing tricks for two seconds
and get, get out of the box.
Yes!
[SOUND]
Eh!
Ow.
Alright, it's time for the green machine.
Habooshki.
Habooski.
Arrgh.
Suck on that.
Uh oh.
No.
Oh my God, my head.
Spinning.
Oh, boy.
Spinning weapons of doom that won't kill.
Oh my God.
Ha ha, what the.
Ha ha.
How did I do that?
All those years as a stripper really paid
off.
I'm doing just fine.
Look at me go!
I'm like a pleasant ballerina.
Aah!
Ow!
Oh!
Who's that Pokemon?
[LAUGH]
That's a potato if I ever.
Aw.
Swimming pool.
Oh what is this?
Whoa!
Okay.
Ow, come here you bitch, you're coming in
with me.
You don't seem to be just enjoying it, let
me just
kiss you a little bit, kiss, kiss, kiss
Very, very hard
That's what she said, ha, ha, [scream]
Oh God, I hate it!
I hate it so much!
Aah!
Ass-assin comin' at'cha.
How do I, how do I?
Aww yeah!
I'm free now bitch!
You're gonna ge- [yell] What do you think of that?
Folded up like a pretzel just for the
right purposes.
No!
Aah!
Why can't Santa get a break?
Whoop.
Uh oh.
[LAUGH]
It's too perfect.
Ball throw.
Big update.
Uh oh.
[scream]
Ball throw.
Whoops!
Uh oh.
The sex machine, really?
Oh.
Timmy may die.
But that is a sacrifice I am willing to
aah!
Okay, this time Timmy's going to die and
not me,
thank you, thank you for not killing me,
ow.
That was a sick trip bro.
99.99, what, what?
I didn't realize this one was such serious
Aah!
Oh ow.
oh.
No, ha ha fooled you on that one, and now
I can make my escape and perfectly time
this 'un
Ow my ass but that is irrelevant for I am
victorious.
[SOUND]
Oh, I don't know how I'm alive but thank
goodness.
Ow, I love killing.
So do I.
Wow.
Where did I go?
Why is my sword a ding dong or my ding
dong a sword?
Red ball throw.
Doesn't red equal dead?
Oh crap.
I'm still alive.
Yeah!
89.999% impossible.
All right.
Let's see what's up.
>> Ow.
My butt.
That hurt.
Okay, nothing's happening.
Oh my butt.
That hurt.
Stop.
Aah!
Take two.
aah!
No, okay.
Oh, oh, come on.
Eh, what.
That was not the way to do it.
The
[LAUGH]
yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I call this one the Targeter, or rather,
my kill them all!
[LAUGH]
Look at the blood!
>> This has been Happy Wheels highlights.
Thanks for watching.
If you like the video and want to see
more, why not subscribe today.
Want to help the channel grow?
Leave a like.
Add it to your favorites.
Or, share with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter.
Thanks again, and, as always, I will see
you in the next video.
Bye Bye.
Do you like my sensual pogo dance?
Do you like it?
Do you like this dance mister hobo?
Do you like my dance?
My dance for you?
It's pretty good, I know.